nous avons la chance aujourd'hui de
recevoir castro c'est quoi pour vous et
puis tu es en tout atteindre une sorte
de sérénité ce qu'il faut pas entendre
sinon on a entendu dans la mâture tu
nous a bien fait rire c'est que se
trouve la question et je dise que je me
sens comme une vieille merde quand je me
regarde dans la glace j'ai envie de
pleurer
c'est toi qui m'agresse tu arrives tu
m'agresses qu'est-ce que je suis beau
ici 35 minutes de paris et enfin un vol
de nouveaux arrête avec ton vol d'oiseau
je connais bien
à oui biensur bien entendu parler mais
l'idole des enfants et tu veux donc pas
ce que je te dis qu'elle passe chez
castro voilà elle est sur le point de se
faire expulser
elle est connue non c'est la fille de
quelqu'un de connu elle couche avec
quelqu'un de connu
nous on s'énerve gagnent un bon travail
on semaine ici je travaille mais je
comprends pas vous entendez à ce point
la france est très sympa je suis choqué
à part ça t'as vu ce qu'on prend dans le
bouquin de nina à cause du pastis à
cause du bonze thich oui caricature
jalousie c'est par à moto dans sa ville
puisse quand on vivait ensemble tu me
tromper avec la terre entière s'était
jamais posée 2 4 confiance au petit
sourire puisque je suis en train de
faire mes chiens n'ont pas envie surtout
de postiches
c'est ma vie privée quand même [ __ ] du
balance ma vie privée sur la place
publique qu'à toi qui passe son temps à
étaler la vie des gens dans les moindres
détails c'est quand même gonflé l'idole
d'apprêter ça n'a pas pris ça moi je
déjeune toutes les idoles des lieux elle
allait quincy comme ça avec mon temps là
la personne n'a jamais osé lui dire
qu'elle limitait pas si bien [ __ ]
c'est jean-paul là bas j'ai vieilli
comme ça moi aussi je te rends compte
qu'ils m'ont proposé la case ses murs
[ __ ] la la la elle est là